MALE SPEAKER: Right.
You're ready, boss.
ROSS BEYER: All right,
my name's Ross Beyer.
I'm with the Carl Sagan Center
at the SETI Institute and NASA
Ames Research Center.
You'll notice my name at the end
of the author list there
instead of the beginning.
And NASA has a large amount of
geospatial data, not only of
the Earth, but, of course, of
many of the other planets in
our solar system.
And this talk is going to be
about how to visualize some of
that data for Mars and the
moon in Google Earth.
In fact, you can do
that right now.
You may not know, but the--
this little button here, this
Saturn-shaped button, it used
to be the switch to sky.
It's actually now a drop-down
menu, and you can also go to
Mars and the moon with it.
So let's do that.
So this is Mars.
And the first thing you see
come up when you switch to
Mars mode is this butterscotch
planet.
And if you zoom in, the data
comes from a couple of
different sources.
And this slide kind of
shows all of them
and also looks pretty.
This kind of low-resolution
imagery and topography here on
the left is actually the--
imagery is from the Viking
spacecraft from the '70s, the
color imagery from Viking.
And the topography there is from
a lower-resolution global
topography data set.
This kind of patch here on the
right, both imagery and
topography, is from a camera
called the high-resolution
stereo camera on board the
European Space Agency's Mars
Express spacecraft.
And that topography is much
better as is the color data,
although it's not completely
perfect.
Because as you can see here
where my pointer is, there's
kind of this band where the
pushbroom sensor kind of stuck
a little bit.
And so you'll see these little
errors from time to time.
They're not NASA-- or covering
anything up.
It's just sometimes
data goes bad.
But in addition to what you see
to begin with, there are a
number of other basemaps
that you can browse.
Of course, there's the complete
Viking global data
set there in upper left from the
'70s, the global colorized
Mars orbital laser altimeter
data set that we use for
topography.
It has a pleasing rainbow color
shade that you can look
at, if you like that
sort of thing.
On the right are two kinds of
data from an infrared camera
at Mars that's gotten a global
data set, both daytime and
nighttime infrared data, and a
host of others that you can
see there in the Global Maps
pane in the Layers menu.
In addition to just maps that
are wrapped around the planet,
there's also of variety of
spacecraft imagery that's been
taken of Mars.
And this has a couple of
those layers turned on.
But basically, all those little
polygons and placemarks
is a spot where an orbital
imager has taken some kind of
data of Mars.
The yellow squares, yellow
plug-ins are from the Mars
orbital camera on the Mars
Surveyor spacecraft that
started operating in '98 and
has now since been lost.
The red polygons are from the
HiRISE on MRO and the blue
hourglass-shaped are from CRISM,
an infrared mapping
spectrometer.
In addition to just these
polygons and outlines, each
one of those placemarks links to
the full data for each one
of those images out
to the various
data providers websites.
And some HiRISE images are also
embedded into the global
layer, as we'll see
in a moment.
Here's one of them.
This is actually the area where
the Mars Exploration
Rover Spirit is currently
driving around.
And this perspective view
a HiRISE image.
HiRISE images are collected
at about a quarter
of a meter per pixel.
And we can build terrain out of
stereo pairs of this data.
And so the posting on this
particular trend is about one
meter per pixel.
And you can see that
Spirit started out.
It landed over there, and it
drove across the plains, and
towards Husband Hill, and drove
up one side and down the
other, and is now currently
exploring this area called
Home Plate.
That's the traversed
path in red.
But the little camera icons
are where the rover has
stopped to take color
panoramas.
Now, here's another view of that
with a colored panorama
there floating in space above
where the spot was where the
rover took it.
And, of course, you can zoom
into those just like you can
with Street View on the Earth
and explore all of these
images down to the individual
rocks and pieces of dust and
pebbles that the rovers
have seen.
To give you an idea, this is a
perspective view in the client
again of the topography
from the HiRISE
camera in Google Earth.
So this is imagery and terrain
created by a stereo camera
about 400 kilometers up.
And if we then bring in the--
I'm going to fade in
the actual panorama
that the rover took.
You can see that we did
a pretty good job.
And you can experiment
with that yourself.
You can explore any panorama
or any layer, of course, in
Google Earth.
There's the little known alpha
slider up here, just above the
Layers panel and you can change
the opacity of layers.
So that's always fun to do, to
get things to show up and see
how they line up.
One of the other things we do
with Mars is we have a feature
called Live from Mars.
There are two spacecraft.
Well, there are several
spacecraft, but two of the
spacecraft are on
Mars right now--
Mars Odyssey and Mars
Reconnaissance Orbiter--
providing us with
near-real-time
telemetry data from them.
And so this is the THEMIS data
from the Odyssey spacecraft.
It may be difficult to see on
your display, but there's a
little white line here.
The time slider is--
this line represents the
spacecraft's orbit.
This purple fin indicates when
this particular camera started
taking an image and when it
stopped taking an image.
And you can see purple
rectangles with images here on
the planet as well.
And those actually contains
data that's
only a few weeks old.
And so at any given time in Live
from Mars, the total data
is maybe about a week old
and has about two
weeks span of data.
So you can see what these
spacecraft were doing just a
few weeks ago.
Let's go to our more near
neighbor, the moon, which was
just launched this summer.
In the moon data, the global
default data here is a
Clementine data set from
the late '90s.
And in fact, this patch right
here, this kind of strip, is a
reconstruction from Apollo
Metric Camera data.
Of course, while the Apollo
astronauts were on the surface
walking around, the poor
gentleman who had to run the
command module, whose name
people rarely remember, is
busy taking orbital photographs
of the moon.
And so this stitch of
data comes from the
Apollo Metric Camera.
And not only is that good
imagery at a few tens of
meters per pixel, but it also
allows us to build a stereo
model of that one strip at a
very high resolution, for the
moon anyway.
This image over here on the top
right is the bad global
topography.
I won't say anymore about it
other than that we have a
spacecraft around the moon right
now called the Lunar
Reconnaissance Orbiter that's
doing a much better job and
creating a much more
dense data set.
The two maps on the bottom--
on the left is a geomorphic map;
on the right is an old
topographic map--
are actually scans of individual
USGS products.
So back in the day, USGS would
make geomorphic maps and
topography charts.
And the Lunar and Planetary
Institute in Houston has
lovingly scanned these physical
maps, and we took
those scans and wrapped
them around the globe.
And you can actually
explore them.
Here you can see these
big tiles.
And as you mouse over the
globe when you have this
historic map up, you can see
that there's a red extruded
polygon there.
And if you click on it, it
actually brings up a photo
overlay of the poster.
And so that actually--
you can zoom all the way in and
read the text and get a
very good example of what the
physical object was like that
was scanned.
And of course, these are
giant posters that are
folded out, et cetera.
And few people have them.
Or the people that do, of
course, have giant drawers
full of them.
But it's a great way to explore
that historical data.
No moon would be complete
without
places where we stopped.
Here is a view of Apollo
11 in Google Earth, the
landing site here.
The image on the ground there
is an old chart actually
hand-airbrushed.
And, of course, we
put in the Apollo
model in various places.
Again, you can see little
panoramas floating ghostly
over the surface.
You may not be able to see
little YouTube icons.
They're a video that had been
recorded by the astronauts
when they were there that's been
uploaded to YouTube that
you can explore.
And in fact, all these little
placemarks record a spot where
the astronauts stopped and did
something in their traverse
through the area.
So you can kind of follow these
in order, or you can
sample them on your own.
The other site-- well, actually
we have all the
sites, but the other example we
have is here of Apollo 15.
Apollo 15, this is zoomed much
more out because Apollo 15 had
one of their little
moon buggies,
and they drove around.
So this kind of shows
the three trips out.
And again, there are panoramas
and movies
that you can explore.
And this has this beautiful 3D
topography from the Apollo
Metric Camera and the panoramic
imagery from USGS.
So, what would we do next?
Now, let me also state that
everything we that we did in
Google Mars and Google Moon,
with the exception of
terrains, because of course,
you can't load in your own
user-generated terrain.
But all of that other stuff is
all done in KML, implemented
that way, and any of that
can be built for your
own purposes or needs.
There's nothing special done.
We haven't hacked the client,
except for enabling a moon and
a Mars and their terrain.
But other than that, all
very standard KML.
It's how we delivered it
from Ames to Google.
So what next for this
collaboration
between Ames and Google?
And there's not really enough
data at this time to support
another full planet from
anywhere else in the solar
system at the resolution that
Google Earth can provide.
But what we're trying to do now
is to implement more data
linkages between NASA's
data providers.
So for example, as I showed you
those rover tracks, those
rover tracks is where
the rovers were
about six months ago.
The rovers are on the ground
and still moving.
And that needs to be updated.
Right now to update that, we
have to do a bunch of manual
processes to upload the data and
to make those things more
contemporary.
And so we're working
with trying to--
rather than having us do it
every time there's a data
change, because we're talking
about a lot of data here
sometimes, is to try and get the
data providers themselves
to publish that data in
a format that's easily
consumable by us and easily
displayable on Google Earth.